sh
okay thanks okay good boage still in
noise but I think you soon also
add starting jary um hey so I'm going to
talk about using Sim wings for an
application in incomplete databases and
specifically to approximate certain and
possible answers Beyond
sets so we all know here in the room
what an incomplete databases and we all
I think agree that this are principal
techniques for managing certain data and
of course the complexity landscape is
relatively well understood right there's
many important results many people in
the room have proven them um and so I'm
not going to go through all of them but
still the fact remains that even this is
intractable even for relatively simple
queries depending on the representation
system that you use um okay an
incomplete database is just a set of
instances deterministic databases called
possible words like for example here we
have three possible words where we are
uncertain about the location of certain
people and some people don't exist in
every
word okay so then uh this gives us a
very easy way to Define query semantics
is basically just we evaluate the query
in every possible word that's just
deterministic evaluation so this can be
applied not just to queries but any kind
of computation you can come up with as
long as you have a deterministic
semantics you can lift it to a possible
word semantics and this gives you then
all of the possible query results you
could get independent of the
uncertainty okay other types of
information we can extract here is we
want to maybe reason about which rows uh
could possibly in the result that's
essentially the possible tles of a
database that is the exist at least one
world where this tle is in this world
yes typically people Define it with
respect to queries but here for me it
will be useful to Define it over
databases and then the certain tles in
the database are all of the tles that
exist in every word right and then I can
redefine certain answers and possible
answers by just applying it to the
result uh applying possible word
semantics and then swing this certain
and possible operator edit okay that's
not practical but let's ignore this for
a second cool good so what I want is
basically a Holy Grail I want some
practical model for uncertain data
management I want to support backs right
we want to support regular relational
databases and maybe perhaps even more
than backs I want ptime data complexity
and this will only be achievable through
approximation since we all know that
this intractability result and want to
support complex queries so what do I
mean by this concretely I want full
relational algebra with aggregation sord
based operations and perhaps also
recursion so I want basically something
that seems impossible right I wanted to
also be model so I want the query
semantics that's closed under queries
everybody working on certain answers
knows that this is typically not the
case right certain answers are not
closed we cannot take the certain
answers of a query and evaluate a query
over it and get certain answers for that
query I want it to be compact I want to
be able to flexibly trade the
for approximation accuracy so you want
some mechanism to compact things uh at
the loss of accuracy and I want it to be
compatible with many existing uncertain
data models and data cleaning paradigms
so what I mean by that is I want to be
able to approximate this paradigms and
then afterwards operate in my world and
run queries in my model okay so how do I
achieve it it's basically trivial as you
will see everybody in the room will
immediately see once I show you why this
works so let's first start with is
generalizing incomplete databases let's
just say we want incomplete database be
want sets and we are all seen like all
of the same rings that exist that we can
use to express things more than sets
natural numbers for backs a Provence s
Rings we saw many variants today and uh
yesterday uh Tempo databases by the way
can also be modeled as Sim Rings um
access control and so on so we want all
of this uh as incomplete versions so how
do we do that well I don't have to stay
on this slide for too long I think
everybody in this room knows what the
seing is it's a set with binary
operations that have neutral elements
and fill a bunch of equivalence laws
like uh both operations I'm looking at
comitative sings for the formal
languages people and uh right have
neutral elements and there
distributivity okay and then we can
apply this to Define relations the idea
is basically if we have some tles and
anary relation over some domain U is
then just the function from the from the
tles to an annotation and with finite
support that means we only allow
finitely many elements to have a
non-zero annotation which basically
means we are using zero to say the tle
doesn't exist and then we directly have
a finite representation system where we
just ignore we don't explicitly list the
tles that we're mapping to zero okay
good natural order also I don't have to
Res saw this many many times and we are
basically relying on natural order to
make all of this work so in a siming
right K1 smaller K2 if we can find some
k s that we can add to K1 to get K2 and
if a s ring this natural order is a
partial order and it builds a lce
structure over the elements of the same
ring then it's an l s ring I think Peter
buan had like a paper uh where this
terminology was used um so uh basically
uh the idea is then we have our greatest
lower bound and least upper bound
operation for any two elements in the
same ring and uh right so for example if
we take the natural number siming back
semantics if we have like K1 is smaller
than K2 it's just the normal order you
would expect in natural numbers and then
the greatest lower bound is min and the
least upper bound happens to be Max but
many other important Sim Rings also have
this kind of lce structure to them okay
so now let let me lift incomplete datab
basis to K relations that's trivial I
just it's still a set of instances just
that every instance happens to be K
relation rather than a set table set
database so possible word semantics
works out of the box because we have a
query deterministic qu evaluation
semantics for same Rings we can just
apply it here too right so that works
but what about certain and possible
answers that's not so clear right so now
what I'm claiming is that we're going to
Define now certain annotations because
now a tle may exist in different worlds
but with a different annotation so now
we have to figure out what's kind of
like the and this is where then the
ordering and this least upper bound and
lowest uh um um uh greatest lower bound
come in so um so the idea is basically
the certain answer the certain tles or
certain annotation of a tle t in an
incomplete database D is now just going
to be the um the least upper bound so
the greatest lower bound of all of the
annotations of the tupple across all of
the different world and for possible
annotations the opposite we're just
using the least upper bound
again across all of the possible words
so this coincides I mean the first
sanity check is of course this should
give us the same thing for sets and
backs as we are used to and it does
right so for backs maybe it's not so
common what it is but for example Lipkin
had some work on this for back is
basically the smallest multiplicity that
makes sense if a tle appears twice in
this word and three times in that word
we say it certainly at least exists
twice in every word right um okay cool
good so far so good let's apply to some
example here I have an incomplete back
database with two possible vers I can
now reason about the possible and
certain annotation for example Peter us
the certain annotation is two since
Peter exists at least two times in every
possible word the possible annotation is
three Peter does not exist more than
three times in any world and for Boris a
certain annotation is zero I was using
this convention to not list tles that
have zero annotation in the tables
explicitly okay great so now we have a
way to do certain and possible answers
over arbitrary K siming uh K relations
as long as if for the k siming k has
this lce structure to it okay good any
questions so far um but that's kind of
like trivial for everybody here in the
room I hope so good now what I'm now
claiming is now let's approximate this
efficiency right I wanted this P time
data uh complexity that otherwise we can
get without approximations okay good so
how does it work now um let me first
Define like a containment where I'm
lifting the natural order now to
databases I'm basically saying a
database is contained in another
database in with respect to sing K so
it's a k Rel K database if uh for every
tle The annotation in one database is
smaller equals than an annotation in
another database and again that
generalizes what you would expect from
containment in sets and backs right um
so uh that means now I can define an
under approximation based on that I'm
just saying some K database D so not an
incomplete one just a deterministic one
is now just a database which is
containing the certain answers it's is
containing the certain answers is a
superet so to say of this database and I
can also do this with over approximating
possible just the other way around I
want some database where the annotations
are always larger equals than
annotations uh that the possible tles
would get also incomplete database okay
good so so this is like definition so
far right but let's see how can we
compute this well and this is completely
uh sorry before we get how to compute it
just to show that we can take existing
representations of uncertainty and map
it into this world so let's say for
example very common things that
everybody here working on probabilistic
databases would know a tle independent
database I'm now using the non the
incomplete version of this we can model
it as a set of certain tles and a set of
possible tles and then the models that
means the possible words encoded by this
tle independent database is then
everything in between that it contains
at least the certain tles and is a
subset of the possible tles okay good
this immediately gives me a very easy
under approximation I just the certain
tles is an under approximation in fact
in this case precisely the certain tles
and the over approximation is just the
thing itself that's exactly the possible
TPP in this case Okay um very easy we
can also do this for data cleaning so
for example let's pick a very simple
type of data cleaning where we have a
key constraint that is violated on a
relation and let's consider all of the
subset repairs that are the minimal uh
repairs that are minimally different
from the original database created in
this case by deletions now um basically
I can uh every such uh I can treat this
as a incomplete database where the set
of possible words are just going to be
all of this repairs and this are
basically all of the databases where
none of the keys appears more than once
that are contained in this initial
relation that violated the key okay so
then what's an over approximation well
it's just the thing itself what's an
under approximation I can basically um
pick all of the tles that don't uh where
we don't have another tle with the same
key not maybe a great under
approximation but just to illustrate
that it's very easy to get from common
types of uncertain whether it be
incomplete or probabilistic database
models or some kind of data repair where
people typically do hor istics now we
can kind of model all the possible words
yes did this use any of your algebraic
structure this slide or is this just uh
no I mean it's basically it's a b
relation here I'm looking at sets I
could Define it for backs too right but
basically here the tables are just set
tables right but they could be back
tables that would work too right so um
and in practice actually we always work
with B tables because we implement this
in actual databases okay cool now good
so now I'm going to Define some new data
model that is just trivial because it
just takes like the under approximation
of certain and the over approximation of
possible and just makes this one
annotation it's just for convenience you
could also just as we will see we can
basically tweat this independently for
most part of the talk but basically what
we're now doing is each tle is now going
to have a pair of annotations from a LC
and K such that the first element is
always going to be smaller equal than
the last second element the purpose of
this will be the first Dimension will be
an under approximation of possible
certain and the second dimension will be
the over approximation of certain uh
possible okay so this is basically a
sing I can show this quite easily there
is this concept of a product siming
where we just take two SE Rings pairs of
elements from them also this pointwise
definition of additional multiplication
is also a same ring so great uh but to
prove that what I have here is the same
ring I just have to show that additional
multiplication stays within this uh
subset of K squ and this is easy because
additional multiplication in same Rings
preserves the ordering so that means
this is also a same ring good I'm going
to use this notation like the downwards
Arrow to access the first element of
such a topple and the upwards arrow for
the second element okay now I can lift
this to databases where just apply it
basically to each tle so I'm just
projecting on the first annotation value
or the second annotation value of this
six okay good so this is for any natural
ordered s ring this is actually also s
ring again based on the concept that
product s rings are same rings with
Point by addition and multiplication
addition multiplication preserves
natural order so this ordering between
the elements will always preserved so
this is like a substructure of the K
Square sing good now
now I can Define what it means for such
a uncertainty annotated database or uad
to bound uh an incomplete K database
it's basically if the First Dimension
under approximate certain annotations
and the second dimension over
approximates so possible annotations
okay good now here's a trivial but great
result um I have already a bound
preserving query evaluation semantics oh
sorry I'm going jumping too fast
I now what I want of course operations
on I want to be able to run queries on
this stuff computations and I want this
to be bound preserving so what I mean by
that is if I have an uad that bounce an
incomplete database I want that for any
query from the class of queries the
query result also bounds all of the
possible query results basically
computations preserve this bounding
that's why I call this bound preserving
qu semantics okay good now I show you
one that is totally trivial and just
works naturally proves itself so for any
positive relational algebra query the
standard K relational C semantics is
bound preserving so why is that the case
well in any naturally ordered saring the
addition and multiplication operations
are monotone with respect to the Natural
order so that means if I start with
something that is smaller than the
certain answers I run a query over it I
get something that is smaller than the
certain answers of of the query result
and the same for possible the symmetric
case or possible so this is super
trivial I mean if you I I can write on
the proof and I'm not a theoretician
right the proof is basically for
addition it's very easy to see because
uh uh like natural ORD defined based on
addition for multiplication you just use
distributivity reorder the terms and you
have it um great so I basically get a
bound preserving query semantics for
free totally for free just based on
standard results yes works for self
joints uh sure it is it's no it's just
right it's just based on the self joints
use multiplication it works for
multiplication so
yes right it's it's kind of surprising
maybe right but if you think about it's
totally trivial and natural right okay
good um this works for any positive
relation algebra query as long as your
same ring has this lest structure
otherwise anyway certain answers and
possible answers in my world are not
defined okay now more interestingly
perhaps if we use a mono siming
definition of um difference the
difference operator then uh if you apply
it pointwise it's not bound preserving
if you think about it this makes sense
right if we start with an under
approximation um this is anti this is
not monotone so but what we can do is we
can define a semantics that works and
how this works is basically the lower
bound of a tles annotation in R minus s
is going to be the lower bound of The
annotation in R minus applying the monos
the upper bound on The annotation in s
and for the upper bond is opposite
basically we make the worst case
assumption for R and the most best case
assumption for S so we subtract the
largest possible element in s from the
smallest possible element in R and this
gives you then again bounce okay
good so um also maybe also surprisingly
now we also get a recurs Ive data lock
positive data lock for uads is bound
preserving we again get this for free
right we just calculating uh
computations in a single K relation so
uh Den's results here from last year
gives us actually some convergence bound
so if uh a Sim ring and this results
basically use um the length of chains in
uh with respect to the Natural order to
provide some quy specific bounds on the
worst case bounds the convergence of of
data lock and basically because in our
case the two Dimensions we treat them
completely independently if if we have a
certain bound n for a query over a k
relation now we get the same bound n for
convergence of this approximations that
we have also completely for free right
nice good okay cool um so how does it
relate to all existing works right I
mean completely for free I have to say
that right so where do we pay there must
be something where we pay right and I
have to admit that we pay in terms of
accuracy often right because we
basically map directly into our model we
approximate early and then you miss some
opportunities where in a an system that
knows the full query and the data um you
could preserve some more correlations
for example that you could use to
compute more precise bonds right okay um
good but uh basically the nice result is
also because we are closed if I take
let's say somebody's favored consistent
query answering algorithm for particular
type of constraints and particular class
of queries if we have a query that is
not supported by that but it has a
subquery that is supported by this other
approach we just use this other approach
to evaluate the query the subquery which
is supported then map this into our
world and then continue in our world so
that means we can kind of utilize all
existing techniques that are out there
we can kind of bring them into the fold
um and this is also replicable again
this this happens because we Define this
closed semantics and this way to map
from existing un incompleteness
representations into our world okay good
cool so that's nice right but uh now if
we want to go beyond um full relation
algebra if we want to also look at
aggregations and maybe also for certain
types of incompleteness um uh they are
not really efficiently representable in
a model where you have concrete
attribute values so what I mean let let
me give you a few examples right one
common problem is that for operations
like aggregation um certain answers are
typically empty because oper this
operation will return a different
aggregation function result in most
words right um so this means certain
answers are can be defined but are maybe
not super useful um also certain types
of uncertainty cannot really be
expressed by just having concrete values
in tles right so for example I can not
express something effectively a person
exists but their salaries between 100
and 200,000 I could express this as
100,000 tles with all of the possible
salary values that are all uncertain but
that's not a very effective way to
represent things right um then also like
operations like sum aggregation May
produce uh exponentially many results
right this is all of the sums you can
get from a subset of a set of numbers
right that can be exponentially
many so um there's existing work on that
of course right we're not starting from
nothing right uh for example I would say
this is related to some degree to
representation systems that use labeled
NS um for example C tables M tables and
uh others um also this is also related
to fact let's let me call them
factorized representations like block
independent databases and so on um and
also related to a lot of uh extensions
of certain answers to uh queries with
segregation where also some people in
the audience have worked on that where
uh instead of returning
uh empty certain answers you return uh
the smallest possible aggregation value
and uh the largest possible aggregation
value this is nice however the problem
with that is now we have not a closed
system anymore I cannot take this
aggregation result and join it with
something else for example and also this
is related to a technique from
programming languages Let me just
mention this called abstract
interpretation where you do sound over
approximations of often of fixo
computations um anyhow so uh what we're
going to do is we're going to take this
idea of intervals but we're going to
make them a fundamental part of our data
model so for any domain that has some or
order we can define an in so it should
that should be total order here um we
can Define some interval domain where we
just have like a lower bound and an
upper bound and this interval is
essentially representing all of the
values that fall between this bounds and
then we want operations to be defined on
this domain in an over approximating way
so that we if we start with two
intervals the result for example of
adding them together should over
approximate all of the possible sums
that you could get if you pick a value
within the left interval and a value in
the right interval and you can actually
prove this we did this for a bunch of
arithmetic operations comparison
operators like here for example any
monotone operation with respect to the
ordering you can just do it pointwise um
other operations you have to be a little
bit smarter multiplication you have to
be a little bit smarter since this is
not necessarily onone um but here for
example is also equality comparison when
is it guaranteed to be equals if all of
the four values are equals when could it
be equals if the intervals overlap then
I can pick one value that would match
okay now we defining relations on that
we take the same same ring as before
this under approximation of s certain
and over approximation of possible but
now we make our values intervals so the
Don that means annotation domain doesn't
change we just change what our our
values are okay good so then uh such a
audb or attribute uncertain database is
then uh encoding also a set of possible
words um that we can get by basically
Distributing The annotation mass of tles
to concrete tles that are bounded by the
intervals of a tle okay uh that's a
mouseful let me show you a concrete
example here we have like for example
two people and I'm showing you two
possible words here for example the
first word I'm getting by deciding that
there's one instance of this tle Boris
with the salery within this bounds and
the second Peters I get by choosing
three Peters in total and each of these
Peters have to have a value between 140k
and 400k okay good so you can see that
this can be used to compactly over
approximate large number of tles which
is what I need for aggregation and also
the things like uh person has an
uncertain salery within a range okay
good so now I can Define also this
bounding again I can Define it also just
based on the incomplete itself I can
also just tweet this as a useless
incomplete data model because it's not
closed under most operations thanks um
so but I can still say like it over
approximates a set of possible words of
an incomplete database like here the one
below over approximates this Incomplete
Back database on top because I can uh
because it has this two possible words
and several others
okay now um good alternative
interpretation is basically that um the
low bound of The annotation still under
approximate certain tles but now with at
a bit level uncertainty so for
example this statement the second tle is
a statement that in every possible word
there's at least two Peters with the
salary within this range right so the
range might not be tight and that's also
how we get efficiency in the end
okay cool good now
um right so um right so queries over
siming relations I don't want to go over
this again here necessarily in this
environment here that people already
know this but we can Define the standard
relation algebra in terms of saming
annotations where Union and projection
are based on addition and join is
multiplication and selection is
multiplying with an indicator function
if the Tupper fulfills the um the
condition then it's the one element of
the same ring doesn't change The
annotation otherwise the zero ring
element of the same ring we are deleting
the tle from the output okay good um so
the nice thing is this all works over
this extended thing too because we just
have different types of domain values
nothing new is required except for
selections right because selections look
at the values of tles so um now we what
we need is basically we need to now take
our over approximating semantics for
this arithmetic and compar and logical
operators and uh apply this and map this
back to the same ring so what we do is
for example if I compare this interval 1
3 233 I get an interval false true which
means the result could be false but it
could also be true um so it's a result
and so then uh basically then how do we
map this back to the scale relation
semantics we just map FS to zero and uh
true to one as before but now we do it
in each Dimension and this turns out to
work
okay good now aggregations which was one
of the main motivation for us to do this
kind of stuff so um basically there is
an existing representation system for Mr
valan and other people uh for
aggregation results um but uh basically
this relies on a semi um module where we
are combining sem ring elements with uh
mono with the monoid domain which
represents our aggregation function um
turns out this uh our inter versions are
of this monoids are also monoids however
it turns out that you cannot have a semi
module that is bound preserving that
would basically I don't I'm not sure
whether it exists in the same ring but
if it would exist it would be not uh it
would violate uh would either would not
be bound preserve okay good um what do
we do we escape into uncertainty we
basically Define another kind of semi
model style operation that is just using
the multiplication in our interval
domain which we already showed to be
over approximating and so this part here
is now for now only in natural numbers
um but uh I think it could also
potentially be extended to other same
Rings if you can under approximate this
stuff too um and then we can do this we
have to reason about which tles have the
same groupy values the groupy values can
also now be uncertain because we want to
also do aggregations on top of
aggregations um and so uh then we
basically have to reason about which
tles could belong to a group um what
their lowest and largest multiplicities
and what their smallest and largest
values and that can give us like a sound
bound on the lowest and largest possible
aggregation
value um we also extended this to
sorting based operations where we use
the fact that we have this uncertainty
of values to represent uncertainty in
the sord order and also can do window
aggregations over the stuff that's our
latest work published this year um good
let me conclude since I'm running out of
time I present to you this uad model
which is a lightwe but pretty powerful
uncertain data model which can under
approximate certain answers and POS over
approximate possible answers po possibly
with attribute level uncertainty um and
I think a fundamental idea here is apart
from exploiting saming stuff is this
idea of taking this idea of ranges but
making them first class citizen in the
data
model good the next thing would be to go
to more uh expressive mechanisms like
iterative computations um and uh right
for also now this interval domain stuff
um getting better bounds because we have
essentially tles of boxes uh and so we
have no correlations between Adit values
and tles so going a little I don't want
to go to full constraints but I want to
maybe use more expressive set
representations like zonotopes or other
types of uh restricted types of
constraints where certain things are
still feasible uh and then also like um
right right now we just have intervals
but you could also think about using an
arbitrary uh partial order for example
like a taxonomy for uh data that is not
naturally has an order to it um so we
have two implementations one is geprom
which is like a compiler that takes like
SQL plus uncertainty and compiles it
back into sqil for any almost any
database and we have a notebook system
that supports a simpler type of this
data model for cleaning operations and
then running queries over this cleaning
operations in the notebook that's called
visia that's mainly work of my students
to and my great collaborators Oliver and
Aaron from Sunni Buffalo and so to show
you okay what so one more thing I wanted
to actually show you also this is actual
tpch queries on one gigabyte database
running in our model right so we can
actually run this we comparing this
again deterministic and yes it's some
overhead this can probably further be
reduced with some smart engineering
things that we haven't done yet um but
we can actually run this on large
instances with complex queries that
nobody could support before right so I
just want to mention that here too and
to show you that I'm not lying here's
like a tle independent database this is
a g prom system I can say I want to do
some uncertain query processing here I
Define how to map from an existing
uncertain data model into our model I'm
saying just this p is like a probability
attribute of a tle independent database
and I'm running Su of a group by B and
right this is running in the background
on the post database if you want to see
what happens under the hut you can see
like the relation algebra trees that are
being generated as part of this at some
point and so on right
[Applause]
you thank for for the talk so you show
us that these Under and Over
approximations behave well under the
relational algebra operation say but you
didn't tell us about the goodness of the
approximation so do we have a
quantitative a way to make sense out how
good are these approximations right so
we don't have any results of kind of a
bounce of how good this approximations
are and that's I think kind of like one
of the things that we need to work on
right uh we have except for some really
trivial results for example uh this also
generalizes existing results on certain
answers like for example for databases
with nulls if you treat the nulls as
constants right and you just evaluate
the query regularly you get an under
approximation and that kind of
translates into our model too but also
that doesn't tell you how good this
under approximation is so I think that's
one of the biggest gaps here right
so
suggestion of
what I'm thinking here of the
inconsistency tolerance semantics of for
instance making I don't know how much
you've seen of that no yeah but I have
to look sequence of improving
approximations ah I see yeah by looking
at fewer repairs for instance I mean or
more
repairs oh I I I see so we basically
what start with like maybe something
that's a smaller under approx an under
approximation that's it's still
qualitative it's not quantitative I
asking if you have any quantitative
approaches here no I I don't right and I
think that's kind of the biggest Gap
there and we know from practice that if
we apply this we apply this to practical
data sets that have data quality issues
and it works quite well if you apply it
but if you another try thing we tried to
use it for is like deterministic
approximate query processing you
compress your database into a smaller
idb yeah right and uh but that work
doesn't work well in in in in most cases
uh and it's not surprising because we
lose all of the correlations so I think
it's kind of going to be interesting to
see what happens if we go to like
zonotopes for example to preserve some
of the correlations how well this works
but it would be really interesting to
have some kind of yeah yeah yeah
exactly yeah along those lines um do vby
semi Rings satisfy your requirements for
L semi rings and monus semi rings and
yeah they they have a letter structure
right so yeah so probability density
functions for example for probab
decreasing uh I guess so right if we can
express it in the sings we're good right
so um I mean that could be one
dire is a semi
but the meat the Dual operation is not
with a
multiplication as long as it exists
right yeah yeah so